[Musique]
ok on va y aller a lancé la procédure
d'activation procédures lancées d'abord
vous veillez choisir ma voix c'est le
test par michel
il a visiblement besoin d'importantes
modifications
j'aimerais savoir ce que représente
cette photo là sur le nov
c'est notre famille je fais partie de
votre famille
robot s'est échappé et myard c'est la
cerise sur le gâteau et pourquoi c'est
déguisé
aujourd'hui c'est pas halloween et qui
es-tu je suis un robot sauveur
multifonctions en fait tu ressemble plus
à un clown a c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas
tort c'est vraiment constitue une menace
et doit être neutralisé
notre planète ne fait pas l'idiot on est
de la même famille maintenant
maintenant on est des amis et que
deviendra robot s'il le retrouve
je crains qu'ils soient démontées
non c'est pas vrai bon alors vas-y
mon statut tu imagines devenir ami avec
notre fils il te faudrait un roman
puissant o
ne ferait pas de mal à une mouche il
s'est échappé du labo il a des problèmes
de communication il n'est pas dangereux
il n'a aucun problème
nous allons le mettre hors d'état de
nuire non il a changé
on cherche des vêtements et une moto
aussi c'est ça non nul besoin
je suis plus rapide attraper
oui n'ont rien des vêtements
[Musique]